who do you see at the top of the pyramid
here
I know that's a very kind of open-ended
generalized question and kind of hard to
answer but I don't know if the Amish
that's what I'm talking about too the AQ
not just people
that's actually yeah
um no I think that so at the tip top is
a spiritual Dimension with the devil I
would think there's a real devil I think
that's the best explanation for why this
same sort of model like continues in
history to repeat
um but anyway beyond that I think that
when you look at these you know big
steering committees CFR Council
formulations if you look at
um Davos these are basically frontus
pieces for this inner core which is the
same structure that's been there it's
that secret security apparatus that's
set up uh you know the oss the CIA 1942
1947 it's the British structure The
Milner Roundtable groups that's who's
running this whole thing